what does it mean to be a star according
to Hedy Lamarr the ravishing 1940s movie
star known as the most beautiful woman
in the world to be a star is to own the
world and all the people in it Hedy once
said I've been an important star and
lived a full life yet I have only three
friends I guess that's all anyone can
expect meanwhile Hetty's fellow screen
diva Greta Garbo so that being a star
means being looked at from every
possible direction you are never left at
peace you're just fair game ingrid
bergman the glamorous star of Casablanca
had a slightly more positive take she
said that being a star means you can
always get a table in a full restaurant
and more recently Lady Gaga offered her
perspective on stardom she said I really
wanted to be a star and I was almost a
monster in the way I was fearless with
my ambitions as these women described it
stardom is isolating and powerful and
monstrous it means striving and
struggling and scheming and always being
ready for your close-up most of us live
a long way from Hollywood but that
doesn't mean that we're immune to the
lures and discontents of stardom there
are stars here at Yale to star students
start professors star athletes prize
winners fellowship winners contest
winners people who get into shining
societies glittering singing groups
people who get scintillating internships
and shimmering jobs people who write
brilliant books and sparkling articles
who emit the glow of Fame
aim and tenure it's hard to be at Yale
without sensing some of the power and
isolation of stardom without
experiencing the monster of ambition and
ourselves or in others there's a lot of
striving and scheming and scrutiny in
the Yale galaxy and sometimes it seems
that in order to be a star you need to
outshine the people around you you can't
be a variable star you need to shine
consistently like the Sun without
wavering or flickering and whatever you
do you can't be a shooting star and fall
through the sky you can never fade into
a red dwarf or collapse into a black
hole even if sometimes you might want to
today is the fifth Sunday an epiphany
the Christian season of stars it's the
season after christmas in the church
calendar the season when we remember the
star that the wise men followed to jesus
and it's the season we read starry
scriptures like the ones today from
Psalms and Isaiah you will not be
surprised to learn that the authors of
Psalms and Isaiah defines stardom a
little differently than Ingrid Bergman
and Lady Gaga and Yale today I'm going
to talk a little about their version of
stardom but before I do there's
something I have to tell you it's a
little personal but it's important for
you to know according to the Bible you
are a star I am a star we are all stars
when God promised Abraham that God would
give him descendants as numerous as the
stars in the sky he was talking about us
our congregation is a constant
think about it okay let's hear what the
psalmist and the prophet have to say
about being stars listen God determines
the number of the stars God gives to all
of them their names God stretches out
the heavens like a curtain and spreads
them like a tent to live in lift up your
eyes on high and see who created these
God brings out their hosts and numbers
them calling them all by name because
god is great and strength mighty in
power not one is missing so according to
the scriptures what does it mean to be a
star or maybe a better question is what
does it mean to be stars because the
first thing we learned about stars is
that there are a lot of them and they
get talked about together and what makes
them so bright is not their individual
glow but their collective glory it's the
way they come together in constellations
and gather in galaxies the stars are a
mass gospel choir of light and they
don't sing solo the book of Job tells us
that when God laid the cornerstone of
the earth the morning stars sang
together and all the heavenly beings
shouted for joy if you're a star shining
and God sky you are not like Hedy Lamarr
shining cold and alone and settling for
just three friends instead you are part
of a heavenly host joining your light
and voice to the rest of the universe
part of the brightness and beauty of all
of God's creation throughout time and
space you are basking in the brightness
of the stars around you
and they are basking and the brightness
of you and together you are making
celestial harmonies and forming yourself
into dazzling patterns when you're
working in your dorm room late at night
you might think that you're alone you
might think that the paper you're
writing only matters to you and your
professor or maybe it just only matters
to you you might think that the only
light you're producing is the faint
light shining from your laptop screen
and whatever dim logical illumination
you can shine on macroeconomics or the
history of sexuality but if you are a
star in God's heaven and you're shining
for God's glory the work that you're
doing in your dorm beams a stream of
light that joins with a light of stars
all over the sky it joins the glow
emitted by an immigrant and East Haven
who is battling police brutality with
courage and faith it joins the gleam of
a sleep-deprived mother in India who is
praying for healing for her sick toddler
and it joins the luminescence of unknown
saints across the world and throughout
the ages who'd pride and are trying to
do God's will and together you all make
a pattern you might not even know about
your combined light illuminates this
dark world and helps the lost navigate
in the night it's not a competition it's
a constellation
the other important thing to know about
stars is that they are all named by God
God creates them all and calls them all
by name ladygaga may have needed to
create herself through a monstrous
effort and she may have needed to rename
herself as well but most of us can rest
secure in the knowledge that we already
exist we are already stars and we are
already ourselves because we have been
named and called by God Isaiah tells us
about the vast universe of stars with
God given names to tell us something
important about ourselves and each other
if God has named all the stars if God's
eye is on the sparrow if God clothes the
lilies of the field if not a hair can
fall from our head without God's
knowledge then we are not just
interchangeable balls of energy burning
at a certain temperature and emitting a
certain amount of light instead we are
castor and pollux ass tyrion and talitha
borealis Nashira and sinistra Regulus
and serious we are shell and Bobo
Heather and lauren james and Jonathan
Kaitlin and Kevin Annabelle and Abby
Marilyn and Debbie Michelle and Jamie we
are all shining together and we are each
known and loved and called by name from
the beginning of the world maybe you
remember the moment when you were a kid
and you realized that everyone else had
thoughts and feelings too and that they
were just as important as yours it's
still so overwhelming and necessary to
realize that there are as many
perspectives as there are people and
that every name represents a being
created by God if we are all stars than
we need to lift our eyes on high
and see each other as the heavenly
beings that we are we need to see each
other through starry eyes and when we do
we will see every crowd every class
roster every list of contacts every
email list every list of the imprisoned
or deported or wounded or dead as a
picture of a shining night sky each name
is eternal and luminous and precious we
need to keep reminding ourselves that we
are all glorious and luminous that we
are all called to shine out with all of
God's children everywhere because
sometimes this can be hard to see with
the naked eye there is a lot of light
pollution these days and the fluorescent
lights of Yale and the neon of Hollywood
can blind us to some of the stars that
we most need to see the star in the East
that guides us to Jesus the north star
that guides us out of slavery into
freedom and the cluster of stars shining
next to us on the Pew I'm going to leave
you with some inspired words from Earth
Wind and Fire that will hopefully stick
in your head this week and remind you to
remember who you really are if you find
yourself in need why don't you listen to
these words and he'd be a giant or grain
of sand words of wisdom are yes I care
you're a shining star no matter who you
are shining bright to see what you could
truly be or in the words of the Apostle
Paul be blameless and innocent children
of God without blemish in the midst of a
crooked and perverse generation in which
you shine like stars in the world
sisters and brothers let's not ask for
the moon
or the Sun or the spotlight or the
limelight we have God and we have each
other we have the Stars amen